un gros dodo une histoire d'olivier si
randy ni illustré par modeste madoré aux
éditions jalan publication ou le nuit
tombe
tout devient tranquille le soleil va se
coucher les étoiles s'installe dans le
ciel les animaux aussi se prépare pour
aller dormir mais tous ne s'y prennent
pas de la même façon le koala par
exemple se colle sur le dos de sa maman
tandis que le petit paresseux d'or sur
son ventre pour un gros dormeur comme
lui c'est sûrement plus confortable les
oiseaux s'installent à leur façon ils
dorment la tête sous les ailes ou sur
une patte ou encore dans des nids ce qui
est sûr c'est qu'ils ne dorment pas en
volant le macaque s'endort en équilibre
sur une branche comme ça il est tout de
suite réveiller si quelqu'un bouge son
arbre en fait ils s'installent sur une
fesse pour ne dormir que d'un oeil
la chauve-souris d'or la tête en bas
bizarre non
quant à l'ours il dort presque tout
l'hiver le hérisson est bien d'accord
avec lui surtout quand en hiver dehors
y'a rien à faire et le hibou lui c'est
un drôle d'oiseau
il préfère ne pas dormir pour veiller
sur toi il s'endormira demain quand le
joueur reviendra au dodo qu'il dorme sur
le sol dans les arbres à l'endroit ou à
l'envers
les animaux ont tous leur petit rituel
pour une bonne nuit de sommeil